en direct avec loïc bonnet directeur du
théâtre à l'ouest de rouen fondateur de
l'association théâtre privé en région
bonsoir merci à vous notre avec nos
logiques abonnés à ses côtés valérie aux
et au delà des plus grands producteurs
musicale en france a notamment des
vieilles canailles 1 par exemple pour ne
citer qu'elles bonsoir à vous aussi
venez riz zeitoun alors loïc bonne et il
ya certains de vos confrères qu'on a
entendues sur les médias cet après midi
est plutôt satisfait par ces mesures
notamment sur la question des
intermittents qui était l'une des
grandes urgences vous est ce que vous
êtes satisfait également comment voulez
vous qu'un directeur de théâtre privé
soient satisfaits des mesures qui sont
aujourd'hui annoncées c'est pas possible
même si c'est très bien pour les
intermittents c'est très bien pour les
artistes puisque la culture a besoin d
artiste a besoin d intermittent mais si
vous n'avez pas de salle pour mettre ces
artistes et intermittents
moi je représente aujourd'hui 80 salles
qui sont des théâtres privés en région
des salles qui font entre 50 et 400
places sont des sociétés privées qui ne
demande pas de subventions le reste du
temps un peu comme l'exploitant du
cinéma qu'on vient de voir le moral des
troupes est au plus bas et on l'a vu
avec ce monsieur bien sûr que ça fait
mal parce qu'on n'a aucune perspective
et parce que aujourd'hui les
perspectives qu'on allait seul peu de
perspectives pour noël sont pas bonnes
qui va venir au théâtre dans quelles
conditions tout ça en fait nous la tpr
on s'est regroupé il ya quinze jours
environ parce qu'on était tout seul dans
nos lieux y avait pas vraiment de
l'association des théâtres privés en
région le ministère savait même pas
combien en été en france aujourd'hui on
a fait leur boulot
on leur a dit bah voilà nous on s'est
regroupé on est 80 on veut bien discuter
avec vous pour justement essayer de de
parler de reprise mais aussi par les
dead parce que très clairement
j'entendais les investissements faisait
ce cinéma mais comment voulez vous
qu'une entreprise privée qui fait zéro
euro de chiffre d'affaires depuis le 14
mars face des investissements enfin ces
voix là et je vous parle même pas de
l'état moral parce qu'on l'a vu avec cet
exploitant mais moi j'ai eu des coups de
fil tout l'après midi des adhérents des
directeurs de théâtre qui sont comme moi
des femmes et des hommes qui ont
construit leur société depuis 40 ans 30
ans 20 ans c'est théâtre là vont
disparaître très clairement nous n'avons
pas eu une seule aide encore alors il ya
des êtres qui se met en place il ya des
fonds d'urgence ont encore parlé d'une
définition de
urgence mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
perspective on attend une date et on
attend surtout des aides pour la reprise
parce que quand on va avoir 30 % de
notre salle en fréquentation comment on
va vivre des aides et après on va donner
la parole à valéry zeitoun des aides et
et surtout une date peut-être deux
reprises parce qu'on a parlé des
répétitions chefs d'état dit voilà iront
pourra répéter mais enfin mais il faut
voir des produits laitiers
oui bien sûr non mais bien sûr alors les
pièces je vais vous dire elles sont
prêtes y'a pas de problème les pièces
elles étaient prêtes avant donc elles
sont prêtes maintenant les répétitions
si vous voulez un théâtre c'est simple
c'est comme un cinéma
sauf qu'il ya des gens sur scène c'est
du spectacle vivant mais si y'a pas de
public
vous pouvez répéter ce que vous voulez
si vous n'êtes pas de perspective pour
savoir comment vous mettez le public qui
va y avoir dans les salles c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment ça la
préoccupation première de ces théâtres
et surtout la viabilité économique de ce
secteur
mais je vois valéry zeitoun c'est pareil
en valais nous donnions les concerts et
les festivals on est tous pareils on est
tous bloqués on se demande comment on va
vivre parce qu'on est des privés encore
une fois les annonces du juste mieux
secondes encore les annonces du
président qui sont très bonnes et très
belle cet après midi pour le secteur
public vous savez on dit souvent que le
ministère de la culture s'occupe
vraiment beaucoup du public mais nous on
est des privés on a besoin de vendre des
billets pour vivre tout simplement
fédérer tout de même constat notamment
pour les salles de concert dans le même
temps c'est vraiment compliqué d'aller
rassemblé peut-être des gens ce moment
dans dans des salles je vous entends pas
bien je crois que la liaison mais pas
très bonnes mais je rejoins monsieur
bonnet dans son constat je crois qu'il
ya eu plusieurs annonces dans dans dans
l'intervention du président de la
république qui est un littéraire avancer
parce que c'est comme ça qu'il a il a
séduit beaucoup de gens lors de la
campagne 2010 cette séquelle c'est
quelqu'un qui est très cultivé
alors la bonne nouvelle
effectivement c'est pour les
intermittents le fait que le statut
d'intermittent soit
assuré jusqu'en juin août 2021 c'est une
bonne nouvelle
maintenant moi ce que j'essaye de
retenir d'un gouvernement et d'un état
c'est combien ils donnent à la filière
pour s'en sortir je n'ai pas beaucoup
entendu de chiffres j'ai entendu 50
millions d'euros pour le centre national
de la musique
j'ai entendu aussi des non sens le fait
qu'un président de la république dise
que nous pouvons faire répéter nos
artistes mais qu' il n'y aura pas de
public
monsieur bonnet le sais comme moi quand
on est producteur ou directeurs de
théâtre ont fait répéter des artistes
parce qu'on a une date butoir et que le
public va investir pour venir voir nos
spectacles
mais faire répéter des artistes sans
savoir quand est-ce que le spectacle va
pouvoir avoir lieu est un non sens total
et il nous rajoute à ça que au lieu
d'avoir du public dans les salles
on va faire venir des jeunes des
quartiers défavorisés pour assister aux
répétitions mais on n'est pas l'armée du
salut
on est la culture française on
représente la culture françaises privées
publiques et on est tous à la même
enseigne face à cette épidémie
mais il faut nous aider parce que ce qui
est en train d'arriver
et ici on regarde un peu plus loin que
ces dates
le corps en un virus et fait qu' on est
tous confinés qu' on ne peut pas faire
notre métier mais c'est des petits qui
vont trinquer parce qu'à la sortie de
cette de cette crise les gros c'est à
dire les entreprises culturelles qui
sont très puissantes jeu
je parle d'universal de sony de
compagnies qui ont les moyens de tenir
parce que l on de du cash flow pour
tenir pendant six mois huit mois un an
c'est pas le cas de monsieur bonnet et
c'est pas mon cas qui nous sommes de
vrais indépendant et qui avons besoin
que que que que nos artistes se
produisent pour gagner des sous et pour
financer nos journaux nos prochains
spectacles donc le le jeu des d'ores et
déjà est faussé et puis je suis assez
inquiet parce que nous avons un ministre
qu'il ya à peine trois semaines nous
proposait de faire des spectacles devant
cinquante personnes avec un seul artiste
sur scène et j'ai le sentiment que les
gens qui gèrent un peu nos métiers dans
les ministères ne sont pas du tout au
courant des us et coutumes et de ce que
coûte nos métiers alors les bagnoles
macro lui emmanuel macron lui appelle la
culture à ceux à se réinventer alors on
sait pas trop ce qui veut dire mais
c'est vrai que au japon par exemple on
sait qu'il ya des pièces de théâtre qui
sont diffusées à distance à la
télévision dans les cinémas est ce que
on pourrait envisager d'autres
possibilités en attendant des jours
meilleurs selon vous l'ong monnaie oui
peut-être enfin moi je trouve que c'est
un non sens qu'au total et surtout moi
je suis directeur d'un théâtre donc un
théâtre si j'ai pas de public et si je
diffusais la télé personne ne viendra
personne ne regardera j'ai pas de modèle
économique et surtout vous savez on
parle pas souvent du tissu social du
tissu dans nos régions dans ces villes
où on a des clients qui viennent rigoler
et c'est très important quand on sort
d'une dune d'une période angoissante
comme ça on a besoin de sortir on a
besoin de rigoler on est un vrai tissu
social pour nos régions
et ça il faut pas l'oublier vraiment
valéry zeitoun effectivement on n'a plus
besoin que jamais peut-être de se
divertir de se nourrir de la culture non
mais j'ai entendu le discours du
président est quelque part il ne
demandait rien
vente est là ou alors j'ai vu qu' il n'y
a pas longtemps certains producteurs au
danemark par exemple on dit ben on va
refaire comme aux états unis dans les
années 50 vous savez quand on allait
voir les films dans la rigole bon très
bien mais c'est pas une solution de dire
à une filière économique
vous devez vous réinventer le spectacle
ça reste une scène une salle et des gens
qui payent des billets pour pour pour
aller voir le spectacle je ne sais pas
comment on peut réinventer
nous notre modèle économique c'est à
dire qu'on a un état qui nous dit bas
essayez de vous recréez parce que on n'a
pas de date de déconfinement réel
ça n'est pas une réponse adaptée je
crois alors pour bord équilibre et je le
répète moi je suis ravi pour les
intermittents et c'est à dire tous les
gens qui travaillent avec nous au
quotidien les techniciens les
maquilleurs etc etc
ça c'est la bonne réaction du
gouvernement et de l'état mais surtout
le reste du discours je suis quand même
assez sceptique
merci en tout cas tournée de loïc bonnet
valéry zeitoun on rappelle qu on en sort
un petit peu plus a tout de même on peut
espérer on l'espère d'ailleurs sur
l'ouverture des scènes de concerts des
théâtres on en saura plus fin mai début
juin a promis emmanuel macron en
attendant bon courage à tous les deux et
merci à vous